in the 90s hollywood movies are a little
more critic proof than they are today
with the general public flocking to
theaters due to advertising
or word of mouth as a result audiences
were sometimes more fond of those films
than the critics
here are the 90s movies audiences loved
and critics hated
director michael bay certainly has his
fans but he's never been very popular
with the critics
rarely has a successful director made
more hugely popular films that are so
widely loathed by reviewers
with bay's transformers movies being
arguably the most infamous
but the 1998 asteroid adventure
armageddon came in for special critical
disdain
legendary film critic roger ebert for
example wrote
the movie is an assault on the eyes the
ears the brain
common sense and the human desire to be
entertained no matter what they're
charging to get in it's worth more to
get out
the washington post meanwhile called it
a film only a dentist could love
but the people well in 1998 the people
wanted armageddon
making it the number two box office
success released that year
with domestic grosses of just over 200
million dollars
so what exactly was the appeal well for
one it featured bruce willis a beloved
action movie star at the top of his game
perhaps more importantly the film also
starred ben affleck who had become an
instant star in tabloid celebrity
after the mega success of goodwill
hunting the year prior for which he had
won an oscar or perhaps it was the
movies can do american spirit of
enterprise
which resonated deeply with a country
far less divided than it is today
whatever the reason armageddon proved to
be one of the worst reviewed films of
1998
and one of its most popular at the same
time
saturday night live has minted many
movie stars over the years though
perhaps none quite as successful as adam
sandler
comedies like billy madison and happy
gilmore which play to the fantasy that
you can refuse to grow up and still get
the girl
seem to strike a chord with 90s
audiences critics have also pointed out
that sandler's comedies seem to give
voice to repressed male anger
the waterboy a movie about a sad sack
who becomes a football star
epitomizes this with bobby boucher
venting his rage being a big part of the
movies movie's appeal
the waterboy represented a quantum leap
in the evolution of sandler's popularity
with france
grossing more than 116 million dollars
more than four times what happy gilmore
had made just two years earlier
charting at only 34 on the tomato meter
however
the movie failed to impress critics
sandler would eventually gain critical
respect for movies like punch drunk love
and uncut gems but the initial critical
consensus was that his movies were
lowbrow
asinine and borderline offensive the
waterboy was no exception
with the bfi calling it a witless and
utterly predictable comic fantasy
and sf gatewriting the waterboy is an
unabashed wallow in the moronic humor of
adam sandler
good news for his fans but most others
may want to keep away
saturday night live wasn't the only
television sketch show making movie
stars in the 90s
in living color ran from just 1990 to 94
but many of its cast members crossed
over to success on the big screen
the biggest success of all however was
jim carrey who found
instant movie stardom on the heels of
his time on the show carey had acted in
movies for a decade before the 1994
triple whammy of ace ventura pet
detective
the mask and dumb and dumber blew him
into the stratosphere
unlike adam sandler the rubber face
comic actually enjoyed a great deal of
critical success
right out of the gate too although in
this sense ace ventura pet detective
turned out to be one of his lesser
efforts alrighty then
but if the first movie was a critically
reviled success then the sequel when
nature calls was both more critically
reviled and more popular
becoming the fifth biggest hit of the
year audiences evidently couldn't get
enough of kerry talking nonsense to
animals
critics on the other hand mostly
wondered why the sequel didn't actually
try to improve on the first movie
for example the new york times janet
maslin wrote that
when nature calls has enough schoolboy
gags and pratfalls to keep aces least
demanding fans awake
but it doesn't have certain basics like
a screenplay
the bodyguard was a movie sold on the
strength of both its stars and an
all-time best-selling soundtrack
at 33 on the tomato meter however
critics didn't like much else about it
peter rayner of the los angeles times
summed up the prevailing view
just about everything that can go wrong
with this film does
and yet it's compulsively watchable so
was a train wreck
but kevin costner was a top five box
office draw in 1992
coming off the mega hit oscar champion
dances with wolves in 1990
as well as a crowd-pleasing comedy robin
hood prince of thieves
in 1991 his star would fall
precipitously throughout the 90s
after a series of epic misfires but in
that moment he was
box office gold as for whitney houston
the bodyguard may have been her
cinematic debut
but she was hardly a showbiz neophyte
houston was already a global pop star at
the time with a number of multi-platinum
albums and number one hits under her
spangled belt
it was her majestic voice that turned
the elegant but simple dolly parton tune
i will always love you into one of the
most cherished of all pop ballads
as well as one of the best selling songs
of all time together she and costner
pushed the film past critical objections
to more than 120 million dollars at the
domestic box office
if there was ever an unexpected box
office conqueror it was the 1990s home
alone
made without any real stars for a measly
18 million dollars the movie grossed
nearly 477 million dollars at the global
box office
as it turned out audiences went
absolutely wild for the fresh face kevin
mcallister
as he fended off a couple of inept
burglars at christmas time
and while the first movie wasn't exactly
loathed by critics
they weren't especially impressed either
not that it mattered to fox
it ended up with one of the most
profitable movies ever
the inevitable sequel home alone 2 lost
in new york doubled down on much of what
critics found
uninspired in the first film
specifically the wild implausibility of
the premise and the schmaltzy festive
sentimentality
more than that however reviewers found
the follow-up more mean-spirited than
the original
in the chicago tribune dave care wrote
the pleasures here are entirely cruel
with an unhealthy concentration on the
suffering of the victims
meanwhile jeanette maslin of the new
york times observed
it's much more violent than the first
film's comparable set of dirty tricks
none of that mattered to holiday
audiences however who turned out in
droves for more kevin mcallister
making the sequel one of the top
grossing films of the year
it was a premise that couldn't go wrong
robin williams fresh off two back to
back best picture nominated films
cast as a grown-up peter pan who has to
go back to neverland so he can remember
what's really important in life
justin hoffman who played captain hook
himself was only a few years removed
from his own smash hit best picture
rain man and julia roberts who had found
superstardom a year earlier with pretty
woman
was cast as tinkerbell match that cass
with one of hollywood's most successful
directors
and the result was well profoundly
underwhelming actually
at least according to critics in the end
what seems like an unsinkable
blockbuster became one of director
steven spielberg's biggest misfires
critics called it overstuffed uneven and
forced and today it has a tomato meter
score of just 29
it made a decent amount of money however
although the gross intake of 120 million
dollars was a far cry from spielberg's
mega hits from the 1970s and 80s
still audiences seem to more or less
like it and the movie has maintained a
fun following
over the decades and is today counted as
one of robin williams most beloved cult
movies
lion kind spying pride natural pig you
lose crude rude bag of pre-chewed food
dude
peter has any actor ever enjoyed so many
career ups and downs as robin williams
every time his critical reputation
seemed to be in jeopardy in the 80s and
90s
williams would bring it back with an
oscar-nominated box-office sensation
of course occasionally his worst movies
could be truly terrible
with williams finding support from
neither critics nor audiences
one exception however was patch adams
which was based on the true story of a
doctor who used humor to treat his
patients
one of william's most unabashedly
sentimental movies it was also one of
his most popular
becoming the 10th highest grossing film
of 1998
williams had just won his oscar for
goodwill hunting a few months before
patch adams opened
likely boosting the movie's mass appeal
critics weren't having it though
joe morgenstern of the wall street
journal wrote like too many of mr
williams recent movies
patch adams wastes the genius of a
peerless clown
end times richard corliss said comics
who want to do hamlet
often end up as here serving big sticky
slices of ham
sitting today at 22 percent on the
tomato meter few blockbuster movies from
the 1990s were more hated by critics and
more loved by audiences than patch adams
eddie murphy absolutely owned the 1980s
saturday night live made him a star at
21
and his first movie 48 hours was an
enormous hit that showcased his
undeniable marquee wattage
everything he touched during the decade
turned to gold even critical turkeys
such as the golden child
and beverly hills cop2 but soon his lack
of discernment in choosing scripts began
to turn off critics and moviegoers alike
by the mid-90s his star had long faded
even before the 1997 legal scandal that
threatened his whole career
in the wake of that scandal the
unexpected happened murphy transformed
himself into a star of family movies
appearing in or lending his voice to
such blockbusters as mulan
daddy daycare and the shrek movies but
it was a remake of dr doolittle that
kicked it all off
critics weren't particularly enamored
with the movie which currently sits at
42 percent on rotten tomatoes
despite the critics however audiences
were apparently clamoring for an eddie
murphy who talked to animals the movie
actually has a surprisingly low audience
score on rotten tomatoes today
suggesting time hasn't been kind to dr
doolittle
but at the time it was massive and gross
over 144 million dollars in the us
making it the sixth biggest hit of 1998.
directed by softcore fantasist adam line
who had previously titulated audiences
with fatal attraction
and the infamous nine and a half weeks
the 1993 drama indecent proposal became
a surprise hit
crossing the 100 million dollar mark
without a big box office draw
robert redford was past his prime at the
time and woody harrelson was only just
transitioning from television to the
movies
demi moore was well known especially
after ghost but she could hardly open a
picture on her own
none of this mattered however as this
inexpensive production became a global
hit
and improbably entered the cultural
zeitgeist based on its premise
a rich stranger offers a cash-strapped
couple one million dollars
to sleep with a wife much like dr
doolittle the benefit of hindsight
hasn't done much for indecent proposals
audience score
but in the 90s the chance to consider
that proposal for themselves
proved irresistible to audiences critics
didn't find much to love about the movie
beyond that premise however
and it currently sits at 35 on the
tomato meter
in his review titled hook line and
stinker david anson of newsweek wrote
that
director line frantically flexes his
technique
turning a mundane household quarrel over
the laundry into a food throwing donny
brook
whipping up mtv style sex scenes utterly
devoid of passion
but not once in the whole silly exercise
does he approximate
genuine emotion there was a considerable
feminist backlash against the film as
well
with critics objecting to the
objectification of moore's character
to add insult to injury the movie was
nominated for seven year end razzie
awards
few movies in the 1990s more widely
divided both film critics and audiences
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one